bill gates crafted a public image as a
likable nerdy do-gooder
gooder office affairs uncomfortable
workplace behavior and epstein ties
reveal cracks in his facade business
insider story
for decades bill gates has had this
persona but pleasant philanthropist
in contrast with the likes of tesla's
elon musk in twitter's jack dorsey gates
was likable relatable and
non-threatening but new reports about
the take founder in the wake of his
pending divorce from his wife of 27
years after a less flattering picture of
the man
reports from the new york times and wall
street journal indicates gates at times
treated the workplace like a pickup spot
making advances towards women who work
from the idea that gates viewed the
workplace as a
a trolling ground for dates may not come
as a surprise considering the origins of
his marriage gates met him began dating
melinda french in in 1987 after she took
a job
as a marketing manager at microsoft the
wall street journal on sunday reported
microsoft board hired a law firm to
investigate b8s in 2019
over claims he began an affair within uh
with a company employing 2000 just six
years after his wedding
earlier this month the journal reported
that french gates has been considering
the divorce
divorce ever since since 2019 and she
became upset over gates willingness to
meet with the scrapes uh disgrace
financier jeffrey upstate anyway there's
a bunch of other stores go ahead
you tell us what's going on over here
you know what regarding this divorce
regarding bill and melinda so for the
life of their marriage i always find
them to be
i mean for lack of a better word very
creepy i just found the two of them
creepy or fake
both okay creepy fake robotic
cyborg-esque
just nothing real about them not even
human right insane wealth
big buying everything trying to tell
everybody what to do
this is the first time i found the two
of them actually human you know when
they're going through some actual
human pain emotion things that normal
people have to deal with
it's the first time the two of them have
ever seen normal now when they announced
that they were getting a divorce like
three mondays ago
the first thing that came to my mind is
what i just said bill wasn't getting
enough sex
and you might laugh about it but sex has
something to do with this marriage
falling apart
jeffrey epstein involved why are you
involved with jeffrey epstein uh
bill gates is 10 times smarter than
jeffrey epstein he's not doing it for
financial advice
to invest he's doing it for other
reasons i don't know what but for
something else
and where does bill go next that's the
question because
look at some of these rich guys that
that get divorced they want to move on
they want to have fun
that there's that one thing in their
life that they haven't been able to
really experience is that loving
relationship
probably with a female and i look
that's part of their problem and i
mentioned earlier at the top of the show
you know one of the other bones of
contention between the two of them now
is the 10 million dollar inheritance
that they were going to get for the kids
so melinda's brought in the estate
lawyers the the
inheritance lawyers and she's going to
amp it up a little bit but for the first
time ever i see these two people as
as human beings and it's it's they hate
each other right now
every day there's a new story and it's
i'm sure bill would like to put the list
what do you think melinda's like behind
closed doors and what do you think
bill's like behind closed doors like how
do you see how do you see each being
like do you do you see
melinda being the loving caring you know
bill you're the greatest ever do you
think melinda is more extremely
competitive we're equal i'm just as
smart as you i'm just as this
oh and then do you see bill being
passive aggressives like dude whatever i
don't even have time to argue to say do
you realize who i am
how do you see them being behind closed
doors when they were married yeah i see
bill running off and doing other things
getting out of the house to avoid her i
see her being pretty tough on him
maybe for not being around the kids
enough maybe not doing things her way i
don't see her as the loving housewife
trying to make bill's life better i
think something that
uh comes to mind i know you're saying
that you know you didn't perceive bill
and melinda as human and almost robotic
i think something just to keep in mind
is no matter how many billions you have
how many zeros you have behind your name
everyone puts their pants on one leg at
a time like it's the same old thing and
it you know elon musk is worth 150
billion
like the only person that actually might
be a robot out there is maybe mark
zuckerberg he's the one person i'm a
little questionable about but
i think it's like you said this is
humanizing gates unfortunately it took
a um divorce for us to actually
realize that he's human uh but i think
bill's gonna be okay i think there's a
lot of
sapiosexuals out there to use a call
back to
daniel shout out to daniel yeah who's
one of the top sapiosexuals out there
and um i'm calling you
it was all that that late night dj talk
um but i think that i think there's a
lot of
women who are going to be very
attractive but he doesn't want a
sapiosexual that's what he's just no he
is
he you know he is the savior's section i
think there's gonna be a lot of women
out there
they're gonna be very attracted to this
newly single
billionaire smart guy eight-year-old
tatted guy with nose rings and
neck tattoos melinda melinda was like
dude i'm going complete
she's going backwards boy yeah exactly
like the guy from uh
why him you know the movie why him yeah
james franco james franco's been getting
in trouble
he's getting a little canceled yes he is
from his own best friend from his own
uh seth rogen saying i'll never work
with him yeah so somebody like him can
you imagine melinda gates shows up with
somebody like him
why him melinda why him why not a tattoo
of a christmas card
you've got this one life and you just
got to go with your gut
you know and that's what makes you feel
good go for it everyone's like
one thing that i think we can all agree
with no matter
what you do you're going to be judged no
matter what you do if you say this and
you think you're right people are going
to judge you
if you if you're going here to the left
or what people are going to judge you so
at the end of the day
i think you just kind of got to do what
what feels right and and uh
not worry about the canceled culture the
wokeness or the people thinking you're
too this you're too that
and uh go with what feels right you know
i think i think bill probably enjoys
life maybe more than we think he does
you know i think some of this is
creeping out a little bit with uh you
know the pool parties back in the day
i'm sure that wasn't just a one-time
thing
i know he's involved in some very very
exclusive private clubs around the
country so it's
and he's a golfer you know he probably
enjoys life so what's the pool party
tell us about the pool party oh okay so
this came out
um that back in the day before he was
married that they were having
um they would hire they would go to sex
clubs in seattle and hire some of the
workers there
to come to the house to do naked swim
parties with bill and some of his
friends that's how
they would blow off steam back in the
coding days in the garage you know
all that all day they need it mm-hmm
it's good to know that he's normal
it's good to know that he's normal do
you like him more now are you going to
switch from apple products to microsoft
products are you going to start like
doubling down on their software and
you know i'll say this about bill he's a
fighter you know he's an intense fighter
a very competitive guy
how competitive does he bring that to
the divorce does he try to crush her
or is he i mean he's got to be very very
careful here right because if you listen
to stories about how he was building
that company
he was tough you know he was very
aggressive very he had no problem
squashing people
destroying people and this you know you
get your gloves up when you're in a
divorce man
i mean it's just it makes you it takes
you to a different place that you don't
want to be
and i think i think the media is
probably making it even more intense
all these stories coming out and them
going through it you know it's probably
pissing them off even more but how long
do you think this is going to last how
long do you think this is going to last
you think they're going to drag this out
for a long time i think they had a head
start on it the way it sounded like they
were having some of this stuff discussed
a couple years ago the announcement was
made yeah so i think they got a lot of
it in place but i think melinda's
probably sitting back and seeing that
public sentiment
is leaning towards her and her lawyers
are gonna smell blood
and they're gonna go for more and if
they see that he's vulnerable i i would
imagine this could get very very
contentious
that would be my prediction i don't know
if it's going to get as contentious as
you're predicting i think this is
something they've been working out for a
while
uh they had no uh
prenup prenup uh sorry about that never
been married with a prenup so
i forgot about that they don't have a
prenup in place and i think this is
something they're gonna work out behind
closed doors i think it's
the media and i think it's just public
perception oh bill gates
he's banging this and he's doing this
and he's having sex with pool parties
and he's just like like man i'm just
gonna buy some more farmland i think
they're gonna be very very uh
i think they're gonna it's gonna be ugly
i really need to scale up one to ten how
ugly ten being the ugly okay ten being
war of the roses
remember that movie with danny devito i
would give it an eight point an eight
point eight
eight point eight what about you how bad
it's gonna be yeah i think the ugliness
is already done
so what's your number oh i i think it
was ugly a year ago and it was a nine
and a half
and i think from here on it's just
negotiation i think it's a seven moving
forward
okay yeah i think they're just going to
wrap it up and be done and move on
i think both of them are probably
looking forward to it i agree i actually
think it's going to be a three yeah
i don't think it's going to be that
crazy to move on
and just go about them and you know who
probably look is looking forward to
the most the kids the kids are probably
like dude
parents figure this thing out and let's
go already how old are their kids 18
yeah they got kids that are adults oh
yeah yeah they got they got a kiss one i
know that they're adults i assume
they're in their 20s what do you think
the youngest was three
no i thought i figured 25 to 35 he's 70
years old almost you know what he
i think kids take sides into divorce or
i think the possibility is there if if
one sta if maybe especially if they're
younger but they can be easily
influenced now here's
the media is all over this story right
now and i think the potential is there
to dig up more stories on bill gates
which could piss melinda on jennifer
captain thinking that this was
a picture of her can't you see melinda
going to her lawyers and say get me five
more billion this is [ __ ]
i just read this story what he did eight
years ago and he never told me but let
me ask you a question here's a crazy
question for you some pictures do you
think anything's gonna come out on her
no i i don't know i don't i doubt my
first thought is no
i don't think so why is that a because
the media has already dug in that bill
gates is the target
and b she was raising kids i don't think
that was probably her nature
to maybe you know wander off i'm not
talking about wandering off that's not
the direction i'm going but other kind
of stories that
could come out about her like what i
don't know i mean some
hard to live with i'm talking about how
you know
like like ellen degeneres stories yeah
that's what i'm saying like i'm saying
like a story like that hey i'm
finally retiring and i'm gonna go a
different side you're not really
retiring the audience kind of fired you
that's kind of what happened you went
from being the lovable
everyone loves ellen to they don't
really love you like they used to we got
to go find the next person to have a
show for 10 20 year run rate until they
fire the next person because get me the
next ellen
go give me the next alan trap for 10
years before the audience fires her
or him it's just kind of how things work
that's right it is the shelf life so if
you enjoyed this little short segment
from the podcast that we did here's
another short segment to watch or if you
want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody bye